hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
modeling the human brain using induced
pluripotent stem cells
ipscs i'm alexis cross of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lappers and brought to you
by stem cell technologies to learn more
please visit their website at
stemcell.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now introduce our speaker dr
anjana nithyanandam
director of operations stem cell lab at
saint jude children's hospital
for our full biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr netanyahu thank you for joining us
you may now begin
your presentation
hello everyone um thank you all for
tuning in
uh thanks for the introduction thanks to
lab roots for um
inviting me to give this talk and to
stem cell technologies for sponsoring it
uh so as was mentioned in the
introduction i am a neurodevelopmental
biologist by training
and i've been working in the ips field
for more than 10 years now
currently i am the head of a human stem
cell lab which is a research-based core
facility in the developmental
neurobiology department at st
jude the main goal in our lab is to
develop and optimize
protocols to generate reliable and
robust models of different parts of the
human brain
and we work very closely with several
pis in the department we collaborate
with them to develop these models and
then to use them to study
pediatric neurological diseases
so i've uh divided my talk into two
parts in the first half i'll talk about
uh what are induced pluripotent stem
cells or ipscs
um some of their applications how can we
make ips lines how we characterize them
and one of the key challenges in the
field in the second half i'll talk about
how ipscs can be used to model the human
brain or different parts of the brain
specifically through generating
three-dimensional
miniature organs called organoids uh how
these organoids can be characterized and
i'll
illustrate a couple of examples from our
work in the department
uh to show how organized can be used
for um disease modeling and in studying
disease biology
okay so uh induced preparedness stem
cells or ipscs in 2006
um shinya yamanaka and
kazutoshi takahashi at kyoto university
made a stunning
discovery they basically found that if
you take fully differentiated
somatic cells fully differentiated
fibroblasts from a mouse
and introduce four factors oct4 stocks
to klf4 and cmic into these cells
then a small fraction of these cells
start to undergo a transformation
and within 10 to 12 days they
differentiate into
these colonies that look remarkably
similar
to cells that you could isolate and grow
from a pre-implantation mouse embryo
they call these cells induced peripotent
stem cells so they basically are almost
exactly like embryonic stem cells they
have all of their properties
this was published in 2006 very soon
they were able to show
that um you can do that you can do the
exact same thing
uh with human skin cells or human
fibroblasts and generate human induced
pluripotent stem cells
now since then the technology has
advanced a lot
right now we have the ability to convert
or de-differentiate
several different types of somatic cells
called donor cells
into ipsc's and this process by which
you can convert a somatic cell into a
pluripotent stem cell is called
reprogramming
uh so for example uh a peripheral blood
mononuclear cells uh from
a blood sample uh dental pulse cells
from fallen teeth or
epithelial cells from a urine sample all
of these um
when uh uh when when we express
reprogramming factors listed here
um opt for stocks to kl4 semic and nano
and lin 28 when we express these
reprogramming factors in these donor
cells
they uh a small faction of them will
undergo the differentiation and
reprogram
into a pluripotent stem cell now as i
said earlier these are
almost exactly like embryonic stem cells
which means that
they have the ability to undergo
unlimited self renewal so they can be
expanded indefinitely
and they have the ability to
differentiate into cells of all three
germ lineages so they have the lineage
potential so they can basically
make any cell type in the human body
now um as you can imagine that the
possibilities are
uh uh tremendous in terms of what these
ipscs can be used for
um the most common application of ipscs
right now is in the field of disease
modeling because
these cells now give us the ability to
create human disease models
the the basic the most simplistic
approach to disease modeling using ipscs
would be
to take a donor cells such as
fibroblasts from a healthy individual
and from a patient
reprogram them into a control ips line
and a patient's specific ips line
and then differentiate both these lines
in parallel
using the same protocol either two
dimensionally on a substrate composed of
extracellular matrix proteins into a
two-dimensional neural culture or they
could be differentiated
in suspension in 3d to form these
self-organizing
miniature structures that resemble
organs or parts of an organ and these
are called organoids
although um these organoids of course
are far less complex than an actual
organ but they are
a more physiologically relevant a more
physiologically relevant model
than um a two-dimensional monolayer of
neural cells
the next step would be then to compare
the cellular molecular and physiological
properties
of control versus the patient-specific
organoids
and that would basically help you
identify disease-specific phenotypes now
an alternative approach would be in case
of diseases that are complex
where there is a large inter-individual
variability
or diseases where the
but the symptoms are wide-ranging uh to
simplify the study
one can use a control ips line and using
a crispr
uh cas9 technology introduced a
disease-causing mutation into this
control line uh and result and
generating an isogenic disease
ips line so this basically this is the
exact same line has the exact same
background as the control line except
for the disease associated mutation
these two lines again can then be
differentiated in parallel either in 2d
or in 3d
and then compare the properties of the
control and disease-specific organized
to um identify disease phenotype so with
this model
um one can study uh as you can imagine
one can study disease onset progression
mechanism
uh the models can also be used for high
throughput drug screening and eventually
um ips derived cells and tissues could
be used in
um uh cell replacement therapy
now um so uh
later on in the talk i'll give you a
couple of examples of how uh
we in the department have used uh
organoids derived from ipscs
for disease modeling but right now i'll
illustrate
the um illustrate how ipsc derived
neurons
are currently being used for drug
screening and cell therapy
uh just to give a couple of examples of
how this can be done
so um several labs around the world
have developed protocols based on what
we know from developmental biology
studies
uh protocols to differentiate a human
ipscs into
a spinal motor neurons motor neurons of
the spinal cord
now these neurons are significant in a
disease called amyotrophic lateral
sclerosis or als which is a a
progressive um
neurodege disease where the spinal motor
neurons undergo progressive
neurodegeneration
uh result which starts with um causing
muscle weakness uh resulting in
uh eventually uh a complete complete
inability to use your muscles
now there is no cure for this disease um
so
there's a lot of research going on in
the als field to figure out a way to
identify drugs or compounds that could
help
slow down the degeneration or treat the
neurodegenerative condition
now all of these labs they also
derived spinal motor neurons from
control ipscs and from
als patient-specific ipscs and looked at
the properties of these
two uh neuronal populations and they
were able to identify a bunch of uh
phenotypic features that were
quantifiable
endpoints to essentially assay
the disease phenotype or the severity of
the disease now based on this uh
information
um the study was done a couple of years
back
where the authors did a high throughput
drug screening so they first
differentiated
an als patient specific ips line
carrying a specific als associated
mutation into spinal motor neurons and
then they screened a thousand
um different compounds uh and looked for
the
look basically quantified the endpoints
that were acid previously
um to determine to to essentially to
identify compounds that were able to
alleviate the
als associated phenotype in these
patient-specific
spinal motor neurons uh they were able
to identify 95 compounds uh which were
then screened again
um through a motor neurons made from a
second
a patient carrying a different als
specific
mutation and finally they um narrowed it
down to nine compounds and then finally
one compound ropinirole which is a known
anti-parkinson's drug
uh which is now currently in clinical
trials um
for als for the treatment of als
um in with regard to cell replacement
therapy there are
two uh uh clinical trials currently in
progress uh where
uh the labs have uh uh used uh cells
differentiated from human pluripotent
stem cells
to um for the purpose of cell therapy
and i want to discuss these two examples
very briefly here
um so in the first case um the first uh
trial is for some acute
cervical spinal cord injury uh which
basically
leads to a tetraplegia or quadriplegia
or basically a complete lack of feeling
or
movement below the neck and shoulder
this trial was started by geron
and uh continued on by asterias so what
they did was
they took a human peripotent stem cell
and differentiated that into
oligodendrocyte precursor cells which
were then in
uh which were then um uh transplanted
into the
uh cervical spinal cord site of injury
right above the site of injury
and uh in this trial the data released
last year basically shows that
um this therapy is safe
no adverse effects were reported uh in
any of the participants and some
participants also
um reported improvement in their motor
skills in their upper extremities
the second ongoing trial for cell
replacement therapy is
um from pluripotent stem cells this is
for age-related macular degeneration
this is being done by multiple labs
the condition essentially causes blurred
vision which eventually leads to
complete loss of vision
so um here what they what the lab did
was uh differentiate human preparedness
stem cells into retinal pigment
epithelial cells these are the cells
that are degenerated in this condition
and transplanted them into the eye and
in this trial
the most recent results show that the
the therapy is safe
no adverse reactions reported and some
patients
reported an improvement in visual acuity
these trials are still ongoing
now uh so the ultimately the most
promising
um uh application of the ips technology
is in the field of personalized medicine
so for all of so all of the
applications that i just mentioned they
can be used in a in
the context of personalized medicine
what does that mean
um it means that we can essentially make
ipscs
from any individual from any given
individual young or old so you take a
patient
either from a screen by skin biopsy or a
urine sample or a blood sample
again somatic cells donor cells which
can then be reprogrammed into a
patient's specific ips line
now in this simple schematic by george
daly uh i
just shows you a couple of examples of
how these patient-specific ips lines can
be used for personalized medicine on one
hand
these cells um can be differentiated
into the cell type that is affected in
the patient
and this cell type can then be then you
can basically screen a bunch of
therapeutic compounds
on these cells and identify drugs that
are the most effective for this
specific patient and administer those
drugs to this patient
on the other hand um using crispr
technology the
the patient's patient-specific ipc's can
be genetically modified to repair
the disease-causing mutation that they
carry and then differentiate it
and then differentiate these repaired
cells into a healthy version of the
cells that are affected in these
patients
and then transplant those cells back
into the same patient so there won't be
an immune
rejection problem and essentially the
the patients are basically getting a
modified version of their own cells
so um that's just some examples of
personalized medicine
okay now how can we make ips lines uh
the the basic uh
workflow involved in generating an ips
line is as follows
so we start with a donor population
let's say fibroblast
which will be plated on a feeder uh
consisting of inactivated mouse
embryonic
fibroblasts at a certain cell density uh
then
there are several ways to introduce
reprogramming factors into these cells
that i'll talk about in the next on the
next slide
so you introduce the reprogramming
factors along with um histone
diacetylase inhibitors like valproic
acid and dna methyl transferase
inhibitors like fiber cytidine
and the idea behind adding these
compounds is to basically ensure
an open and accessible chromatin in
these
donor cells so that they're able to
interact with the uh
reprogramming factors now when you do
that um
depending on the protocol um in two to
three weeks you will
see that a small percentage of the donor
fibroblasts have now undergone
transformation and the differentiation
and reprogrammed into a clone
okay so these are ips clones you may
also see depending on the method used we
may also see several
partially transformed cells on the
same dish and those can be ignored it is
important here to note that each ips
clone on the dish
comes from a single reprogramming event
and a single a donor cell so a single
donor cell undergoes reprogramming and
gives rise to an ips clone
now this dish can then be light stained
for pluripotency markers like crow 160
and ssea4
and the the clones that stay in positive
uh
we would then pick and expand these
clones but this time we would
expand them on a feeder-free surface
comprising of a mix of different
extracellular matrix proteins
um and this substrate is the most
commonly used substrate is nitrogen
uh once these clones are expanded now we
know that they
express a pluripotency markers but
oftentimes the clones may not be able to
sustain their fluid potency so they need
to be
passaged a few more times to ensure that
they're able to sustain the purity
potential
at the end of um at the end of this
process if you have a good ips line it
will have a good morphology tightly
packed
colonies no differentiation a bad ips
line
will have tightly packed ips colonies
but will be surrounded by a lot of
spontaneously
differentiating cells and those clones
basically can be discarded
we take the good ips clones and we
continue um
uh growing them uh in hypoxic conditions
there have been some
studies recently which show that ips
lines grow better
or or with fewer um fewer chromosomal
abnormalities
uh and and they are better and healthier
uh when grown in
five percent under hypoxic conditions
and we almost always use
empty surplus from stem cell
technologies as the growth media
now uh there are different ways to
introduce the um
reprogramming factors into the donor
cells the three most common methods are
one using episomal plasmids which is
basically a set of plasmids that code
for the
programming factors these can be
introduced into the donor cells by
nuclear faction
for example they they do not integrate
into the genome they stay extra
chromosomal where they
uh uh where they will express themselves
uh
another uh the second uh most common
method is using sendai viruses um
where uh basically we've generated a
a modified non-transmissible form of the
semivirus vector which is a single
standard r name
which again does not integrate with the
genome it basically replicates
and undergoes translation uh in the
cytoplasm
and the third method which is my
personal favorite is using
um synthetic modified mrnas which code
for the reprogramming factors
uh these mrnas are modified um as shown
here
uh to uh to basically not trigger
the cells um the innate cellular immune
response
uh which can uh which can affect the uh
stability of the
mrna and translation efficiencies the
modification basically make sure that
the mrna is stable and is able to
undergo
translation efficiently uh and here's a
table uh summarizing some of the pros
and cons of each of these methods
uh briefly uh episomal plasmids are
affordable
but they they do require a large number
of ips clones to be screened because
the the rate of aneuploidy in the ips
lines that you get
that you get from using episomal
plasmids is is a bit higher than the
other methods
uh plus a um one one needs to passage
ips lines uh
at least 10 times before you can
completely get rid of the plasmids from
the cytoplasm of those ipscs
and that is important because we don't
want these reprogramming factors to
continue expressing
ectopically when you're trying to
differentiate your ips lines
uh towards uh specific cell lineages
uh sentiviruses are very commonly used
they are expensive but they um
they uh reprogram very efficiently they
are highly reliable
that employee rate is low but once again
you need to do about 15 passages to
completely get rid of those
viral vectors from the ips lines before
downstream differentiation
the mrna methods are the mrna method is
expensive
um how is expensive but offers the
highest
efficiency of reprogramming very low
unemployed rate and
one required one needs to do only about
five passages before the
lines are ready for uh downstream
differentiation
um okay so once you have uh picked your
ips clones and expanded them
uh made sure that they are able to
sustain their pluripotency the next step
is to characterize them next step is to
validate them and make sure that they
are truly pluripotent there are three
main aspects of the characterization
the first one is to confirm the
expression of
pluripotency genes which can be done by
simple immunostaining
there are a bunch of markers uh cell
surface markers as well as transcription
factors
that are expressed by fluoride
potentials to do a more quantitative
essay
one can do a flow cytometric analysis um
shown here are two ips lines uh the
first one um
uh uh almost all cells express both
potency markers at very high levels
in the second line you can see there is
a small fraction of um cells in this
population that do not express either of
the pluripotency markers and that's prob
that's a sign of spontaneous
differentiation
in this line so it's not as good a line
as the first one uh for a
for an even deeper analysis you could
analyze yourselves on a microfluidic
array loaded with stackman probes such
as this one
which will basically look at the
expression of several genes associated
with pure potency and differentiation
and one could do a similar essay on a
gene expression microarray
such as this one from asymmetrics the
um the second aspect of characterization
is to look at the trilineage potential
of your ips line whether it is able to
differentiate into all the cells of all
three germ lineages ectoderm mesoderm
now there are two ways to do this uh you
can do it through an unbiased
differentiation approach where
you basically um let the ipscs undergo
default differentiation
into a culture which is a mix of cells
from different lineages without pushing
the line it towards any specific uh
lineage um an alternative approach is to
do a directed differentiation where
you're essentially
pushing your ips line specifically
towards ectodermal mesodermal and
endodermal lineages by adding a specific
signaling molecules and morphogens into
the medium
this is the method that we prefer to use
in our lab there are also several
commercially available
kits such as this one from stem cell
technologies which allows you to do
your tri-lineage differentiation through
a directed
through directed approach
okay so once you have your culture these
can be analyzed by
rtq pcr for markers of the different
lineages so
uh in our lab we use a customized
attackman array
uh where uh where we're basically
looking at the expression of seven genes
for each lineage and um
but you can also do a deeper analysis so
for example using a scorecard essay
such as this one which basically looks
at the expression of a lot more
markers for each of the lineages
um okay so and
finally the the third aspect of
characterization of ips lines is
looking at genomic integrity now uh
ips lines of are known to carry
structural abnormalities and
copy number variations uh some of those
are listed here the most commonly
occurring
abnormalities are listed here and most
of them
offer confer a growth advantage to the
cell so the abnormal cells will quickly
take over the entire culture
so it's very important to able to to be
able to identify them early on
now what is the reason for these
structural variations in ips lines there
are
several causes uh for example um if you
if your donor population
is carrying a specific cohort of somatic
mutations and that basically gets
carried on
to the ips line that was generated from
reprogramming that particular
donor cell another reason could be a
sub-optimal culture condition so we know
that the longer you carry
you culture ips lines in vitro the more
the chances of them acquiring um
genomic uh genomic um
problems as well as epigenetic mutations
um uh in addition to that for example
single cell passaging
versus passaging you're called passaging
your lines as pieces of colonies uh
makes a difference in terms of the
uh genomic health of these lines uh if
you let your cultures grow
beyond 80 percent confluency that seems
to affect their uh
their carrier type as well and as i said
prolonged in vitro culture so basically
optimal uh
uh handling of these ips lines not
letting them over overgrow
always passaging them in pieces and not
a single cell
is important to avoid
these structural abnormalities and copy
number variations
um so how do we how do we make sure that
the lines are are good
genomically the simplest assays are g
banding and g banding and spectral
karyotyping
so uh here for example we have a line
where 93 percent of the population has a
normal karyotype but seven percent of
these cells have a trisomy in a
chromosome
20. and here we have a line where
there is a massive duplicate that we
have a normal line and then there is a
line
where we have a massive duplication in
chromosome 20 so chromosome 20
abnormalities are very common in
human uh es and ips lines
um for a more for a deeper analysis you
can also analyze these lines on
for a higher resolution analysis you can
also look at them on snp
arrays such as this one from aluminum
the la will basically detect copy number
variations in dells
translocations and snps as long as
they're present
in at least 20 percent of the population
so gives you a digital karyotype of the
line
and several labs uh also uh uh prefer to
do
whole genome sequencing so you can
detect all your deletions insertions uh
somatic uh
uh somatic uh sorry single nuclear
variants and the nobel variants etc
okay so one of the key challenges in the
ips field is a phenomena
called interline variability basically
means that if you take a population of
donor cells and you derive
two ips lines in the same reprogramming
experiment to derive two
independent ips clones or ips lines from
this donor population
and differentiate both of these lines
using the same protocol the lines might
actually
behave slightly different from each
other in terms of their
differentiation potential and lineage
bias
uh so now why is that although they were
both derived
from the same population of donor cells
in the same reprogramming experiment
so there are there could be many causes
for interline variability uh
the two main causes that i'll talk about
here one is
if you have a heterogeneous donor
population as i mentioned earlier every
ips clone ips line comes from the
reprogramming of a single donor cell as
a result of a single reprogramming event
so if you have a heterogeneous
population of donor cells
which are where the different cells
carry different cohorts of some
somatic mutations those mutations
basically are going to get transferred
over to the ips lines that come from
these cells
and resulting in a heterogeneous group
of ips
lines derived from the same donor
population the second reason
um could be aberrant epigenetic
resetting so what is epigenetic
resetting
now during reprogramming um you start
with a donor somatic cell
where this is a fully differentiated
cell so all the pluripotency genes
are repressed which means they carry uh
hypermethylated promoters and
repressive histone modifications such as
the lysine
9 and lysine 27 trimethylation whereas
all the cell type specific genes are
active
so they have hypomethylated promoters
and they carry activating histone
modifications like lysine 4 methylation
and acetylation
now during reprogramming this somatic
cell erases all of its epigenetic marks
and re-establishes
new epigenetic mass basically
re-establishes its epigenetic landscape
so that the resulting ips line will
will will have all pre-potency genes
active with hyper-methylated promoters
and activating histone modifications and
all the cell type specific genes in the
ips line will be repressed
uh so hypermethylated promoters and
repressive histone modifications
now if this process of re this process
is called epigenetic resetting
by the somatic cell is basically erasing
all of its epigenetic marks and
re-establishing new marks
to become a pluripotent stem cell now if
this process of epigenetic resetting
happens perfectly
then when you differentiate this ips
line it should be able to differentiate
into cells of all three lineages
with equal efficiency and low bias
often times however this does not happen
perfectly
and the the resetting process can often
be incomplete or aberrant
now this is a random uh process and it
can vary from
uh it can vary between every single
reprogramming even but what happens
is that you have a donor somatic cell
which undergoes reprogramming into an
ips line which
does express the pluripotency genes
however
the depression of the cell type specific
genes might be incomplete or aberrant
as a result you have an ips line which
is pluripotent so it is able to
differentiate into cells of all three
lineages
however because of this incomplete
repression of cell type specific genes
it might have a skewed differentiation
potential or a lineage bias
now if you derive let's say six
different ips clones from a single donor
population
now because uh epigenetic resetting uh
is
abundant epigenetic resetting is random
and because it can be different in every
single reprogramming event
and because all all of it all of all of
these six clones each clone comes from a
single reprogramming event
you you end up with six clones which
might have slightly different
epigenetic profiles and therefore
slightly different lineage bias
resulting in interline variability now
eventually we might be able to
optimize and standardize the method of
reprogramming that gives us the highest
quality ips lines
with complete epigenetic resetting and
no no lineage bias
however right now the most common common
way to address this availability issue
is by screening
so the the idea is to uh generate
multiple clones from each donor
so let's say six ips clones from each
donor and then you would
uh uh screen these uh clones and
identify at least three clones per donor
which have
which are best suited for your uh
purposes
and then differentiate all three ips
clones from each donor
uh into uh organized or whatever
downstream differentiation that you want
to do
and then you would analyze basically
organoids from all of those three clones
so the idea here is that if you see a
phenotype in
organoids from all three ips clones um
then you can be uh confident that that
phenotype is the consequence of the
genotype of the individual and not
because of some inherent um
inherent bias in the in the line itself
so this a screening of ips lines there
are several ways to do that um i'll talk
about two essays here uh the essay that
we do uh
most uh uh commonly or routinely in the
in my lab
is a cellular assay because our our goal
is neurological
uh uh disease modeling or therefore
neural differentiation
uh we do us we do a rosette formation
essay where we take ips lines and um we
aggregate them in these um
aggravals uh to form embryoid bodies in
this neural induction media with
from stem cell technologies uh after a
few days we then
played these android bodies on a
substrate um of course
for because they are growing in this
neural induction media they should be if
for a good ips line uh the android
bodies should be able to form these uh
you know these
these uh neuro epithelial structures
called rosettes
uh if you have a go if you have a line
with high neurogenic potential a 95 to
100
percent uh it will be 95 100 percent
efficient in forming neutral reset
but if you have a bad ips line uh then
either the
efficiency will be low or the you'll
have a culture which would be a mix of
neutral process and
non-neural cells so a cellular assay
such as this one especially for neural
differentiation
is a quick and simple uh to identify
clones which are which have
a decent neurogenic potential which have
a good neurogenic potential
for a deeper analysis you can also uh
analyze your ips lines on methylation
arrays such as this one from
aluminum and you could either look at
the global methylation profile
of your ips lines and compare them to
the donor population
and that might that might help you
predict lineage bias or you can look at
the methylation at specific
um promoters of genes associated with
pluripotency and differentiation
and this sort of methylation pattern can
again help you predict lineage by so for
example
in an ideal situation if you have a high
quality ips language does not have
lineage bias
then the promoters of all
differentiation of cell type specific
genes of ectodermal mesodermal and
endodontic lineages
should all have hypermethylated
promoters
okay so to summarize the first part of
my talk i basically showed you that
ipscs can be derived from multiple donor
cell types using multiple
non-integrating approaches
ipscs can undergo unlimited self-renewal
and have high lineage potential
uh to characterize and validate ips
lines uh we need to look at the
expression of pluripotency markers we
need to
check their genomic integrity
periodically as well as
demonstrate that ability to
differentiate into ectoderm endoderm and
mesodermal lineages
uh the applications of ips technology in
disease modeling drug screening cell
replacement therapy and most importantly
this allows for personalized medicine
which is still a few years away but that
is uh the
eventual goal uh interline variability
um amongst ips lines derived from the
same donor is a key challenge
at the moment the most common way to
address this issue is by deriving and
screening multiple ips clones
per donor and to do the screening you
can do cellular assays or
methylation arrays
okay so now the second part of my talk
uh i'll be talking about
how we can use ipscs to model uh the
human brain
now uh differentiating ipscs into brain
organoids uh
broadly um comprises of four main phases
so uh that these four phases are neural
induction
expansion differentiation and maturation
so a neural induction uh begins with
um dissociating ipscs into single cells
and re-aggregating them
uh at a at a defined number of uh with
the defined number of cells per
aggregate in a low attachment uh place
such as
a low attachment 96 well played these
cells will re-aggregate
um in the right media uh to form these
embryo bodies
uh the embryo the this this uh the
android body is basically the cells of
the android bodies depending on the
growth factors and cytokines and
inhibitors provided in the media
they'll undergo uh regionalization and
sulfate specification
and they will um proliferate into these
neuroepithelial these self-organizing
neuroepithelial structures that have a
lumen
and they are surrounded by a region
specific uh progenitors
and they have an apical basal polarity
uh the next phase is neural expansion
where these region specific progenitors
start proliferating they expand
they also get specified into lineage
specific precursors
and some of these precursors also start
differentiating for example in this
double reporter line
you can see that organoid still is
comprised of
mainly of progenitors in green but some
of these progenitors are starting to
differentiate
shown in red here so the onset of
differentiation starts with the neural
expansion phase
uh the differentiation of the lineage
specific precursors
um continues in the neuronal
differentiation phase
uh during this phase it is important to
um important to provide conditions for
good uh
nutrient and gas exchange for these
organoids and so we typically grow these
organoids in these
mini bioreactors uh which basically um
uh
will will agitate the organoids and
allow for nutrient exchange and we know
from
comparing rna-seq data of retinal
organoids grown with and without
agitation that
agitation significantly reduces
hypoxia-induced pathways in these
organoids
and organize just grow better when they
move around like this
as opposed to when they're just grown in
mobile in a plate
so that's neural differentiation and
this is then followed by
maturation which we almost extensively
for which you almost extensively use the
brains media again from stem cell
technologies
during the maturation phase as you
organize mature you'll start seeing the
expression of
synaptic proteins expression of for
example here glutamate transporter
and for organized such as cortical
organoids when when you played these
organoids and multi-electrode arrays and
look at the spontaneous activity you
will you'll start seeing spontaneous
neuronal networks
network bursting and oscillations uh all
signs of the fact that these uh the
neurons within these organoids are
maturing
so these are those are broadly the four
main phases now
labs different labs have their own um
customized optimized protocol
for differentiating ipscs into different
types of organoids of the brain
however there are also commercially
available kits such as this one
um from stem cell technologies uh which
can also be used uh
for um differentiating ipscs into brain
organoids
okay so now once you have an organoid
the next step is to determine how
closely does this organoid resemble
the region of the brain that you're
trying to model or mimic
now characterizing these models uh again
involves three main aspects there are
several assays that you can do for
characterizing your orders but the three
main aspects of it
the first one is the immunostaining
which is basically which involves simply
sectioning the organoids and staining
them
for um sustaining them using antibodies
against specific cell type
markers cell type specific markers and
genes here for example we have a bunch
of
rostral hind brain organoids that we
made in the lab and we've stained them
sectioned and stained them in
collaboration with the northcott lab
to look for the presence of to check the
presence of a certain specific cell type
so
uh immunostaining is the advantage of a
quick immunostaining is first of all
it's a good way to determine if you are
going in the right direction if you are
different if you are differentiating the
right
lineages just to confirm the presence of
specific cell types that you expect to
see in the brain region that you're
trying to model
it also shows you cellular organization
and cyto architecture within the
organoid itself if the cells are
layered uh they're laminated and the
distribution and localization of the
cell of the different cell types
relative to each other so it gives you
um
it gives you uh an idea of how well
the organoids the cells are organized
within the organoid structure
um and is it similar to what you would
uh see in vivo
uh the second aspect of characterization
is by is looking at the transcription
profile uh so you want
you could do a bunch of rtq pcrs or you
can do bulk rna-seq or more commonly
what's becoming more and more common in
the field
is to do a single cell rna feed and here
are some examples of single salary speak
data published
by different labs uh the um
the advantage is that this basically uh
the essay tells you
uh what proportion of a cell types of
different cell types are present in your
organoid
uh if you have the and it also tells you
if you have uh
cell types that you do not want in your
organized system so
so cells from the neighboring lineages
or neighboring parts of the brain
the undesirable cell types so um
so this is a more quantitative analysis
of your organ
of the composition of your organoid
and the third uh aspect of
characterization is to perform a
functional as you know because we have a
brain organoids
so we are our the functional assay is
essentially the
the best way to uh sort of demonstrate
the physiological relevance of your
organoid model
so for brain organoids we want to know
if they have a functional neurons if
they have a neurons that can actually
form a neural network and function
and and fire spontaneously uh so
in our then again there are different
ways to do this but in our lab we
typically uh plate organoids on these
multi-electrode arrays uh we have a
system from axion
biosystems uh here we have a grid of 16
electrodes
and there's a critical organoid that we
have plated on these
the multi-electrode array essentially
measures
extracellular field potential uh which
is
uh which is a direct consequence of the
firing of action potentials uh
action potential by the neurons which
are which are in contact with these
electrodes
now if you when you have a in cortical
organoids when you have
um a mature cortical organoid of
these neurons which with a dense network
of neurons
they will basically communicate with
each other and fire synchronously
um as shown here uh where you can
so basically each of these uh raster
plots is from a separate organoid
and on the x-axis is the time and on
y-axis is the 16 different electrodes
basically each line each vertical line
here represents
um the firing of an action potential so
as you can see here
you have a bunch of electrodes firing um
uh synchronously you're fighting firing
um
at the same time which basically
suggests that there is a network of
neurons across
these 16 electrodes and um and this is
this is what you would expect in a
hundred day old cortical organoids
um notice here that each of these
organoids has a slightly different
pattern of firing but they all
are able to fire uh these neuronal uh
these network bursting or network
oscillations
okay uh so um so a challenge
just like ips lines uh the the challenge
in in the organoid field is variability
amongst organoids
now um organized generated within uh the
same
experiment within the same batch as well
as organized between
independent experiments using the exact
same protocol can be quite variable
uh we have seen variability in yield
we've seen variability in size for
example here we have a bunch of
cortical organoids which are highly
variable in size we've seen variability
in the morphology of the organoids
so um here we have a batch which has a
bunch of
a good looking dense um organoids with
smooth translucent edges but we also
have a ton of cystic organoids
um we here is a reporter line um a bunch
of cortical organoids expressing a
reporter now we have some organizers
expressing the reporter very
um very efficiently and strongly and we
have a bunch of organoids
with no reported expression this is
within the same batch then here we have
a bunch of caudal forebrain organoids um
expressing a different reporter again
you can see there's some organized with
strong full expression of reporters some
with weak expression
some without any expression at all and
some uh expressing the reporter in a
in patches throughout the organized so
the variability can be quite
um quite significant so what is the
reason for this variability
um there there could be many reasons but
the two reasons that we are focusing on
resolving in the lab are um first um
uh if you start with a heterogeneous a
population of ipsc so if you have
uh a a population of ips cells which are
already heterogeneous with
with regard to their genetic uh uh with
regard to their genomic abnormalities or
their epigenetic
profile uh because the uh because the
process of differentiation starts with
dissociating these ipc's into single
cells and then re-aggregating them in
defined cell numbers
the uh the proportion of a good and bad
ips cells that you
are that you end up plating in every
single well of that 96 well plate
might be different so your starting eb
might be actually a very heterogeneous
within a single 96 well plane
as a result of which the organize that
you get eventually from those eb's will
also be variable so
a heterogeneous starting population of
ipscs could lead to huge variability
the second reason could be a low
efficiency of the differentiation
protocol so whatever morphogens whatever
signaling molecules and and cytokines
and inhibitors you're adding to the
media if they are
if the efficiency of them uh influencing
cell
causing uh cell phase specification
influencing differentiation is not
um complete then that can also uh lead
to a lot of variability depending on how
many cells or which cells are getting
exposed to the morphogens and
and which are which cells are able to
actually respond to the morphogens
so um right now uh to
address the variability issues um to
address the heterogeneity issue
um what we do is um uh frequent
karyotyping so the the general consensus
in the field is to carry type your ips
lines every five passages
but we probably do it more frequently
than that so frequent karyotyping just
by g
banding and spectral karyotyping will
give you an idea of how if your lines
are still
maintaining their um genomic health uh
however we don't know about the
epigenetic changes taking place in these
lines
and then optimal handling like as i said
before um handling of the ips lines uh
never letting them over grow or grow
beyond 80 percent confluency for example
uh and just
passaging them and maintaining them the
craft preservation just optimal handling
conditions of the ips lines
also helps in maintaining uh the
maintaining a healthy line and therefore
reducing availability downstream
um and in order to address the the
efficiency issue of the differentiation
protocol that you're using uh
my recommendation would be to use a
reporter line wherever possible
now we've had issues with some of the
protocols that we we've tried to develop
to model different
parts of the brain and uh using a
reporter line is very is extremely
helpful
in uh optimizing your protocol uh in in
in determining the variability in your
protocol the
variability in your system in
determining the
efficiency of your system so wherever
possible use a reporter line and then we
can also use these uh
reporter lines to essentially screen
organoids at an early stage
uh screen organized that are expressing
the reporters versus organized that
don't express a reporter well for
example and before before uh
uh before doing the more um uh
detailed experiments or downstream
analysis at an early point during
differentiation you could use the
reporter line to screen the healthy
organoids so the good organoids
so i'll give you an example here so here
we have a culture
a batch of caudal forebrain organized
expressing a
cardinal four brain specific reporter
now um
you can see this argonaut is a mix of
this this population is a mix of
organized expressing the reporter
marked here with the yellow asterisk
aspect and then we also have organized
uh marked here with the blue
asterisk which don't express the
reporter at all and we have we have all
of these argonauts growing in a single
batch
so now what we did was we basically
compared the
gene expression profile by bulk rna-seq
of uh organoids which were made from a
line from a non-reported line so we
basically collected a bunch of
unscreened organoids
and then we made organoids using the
same protocol from the reporter line
and we screened for the reporter
expressing organized and then uh
did a bulk rna-seq on those organoids
now in this heat map which is a subset
of the rna-seq data
we are looking at the expression of
caudal forebrain genes and dorsal for
brain genes and each row here represents
a single organoid one organoid basically
and as you can see in the reporter's
screen if you look at the reporter
screen organized they almost all look
almost exactly similar with a high
expression of
caudal forebrain genes and low
expression of dorsal for brain genes but
if you look at the unscreened organoids
not only do they have a completely
different expression profile
they also their organelles also differ
from each other
quite a bit in terms of the level of
expression of the different genes
so um if whenever possible use a
reporter line and use that to screen
organoids before you start doing the
more uh
the the bigger downstream experiments
um okay so now i want
to uh give you uh two examples of
disease modeling using ipscs and
ipsc-derived organoids that we have done
in the lab in collaboration with pis in
the developmental neurobiology
department at century
the first uh example is a project we did
in collaboration with dr mike dyer
um uh where where the goal was to model
human retinoblastoma in order to
identify the cell of origin of this
tumor
and uh to provide a model for
pre-clinical testing
now the uh the uh our role
or our job in this collaboration was to
uh develop and optimize a proto a highly
reliable and efficient protocol
that could differentiate any ips line
um into a retinal organoid and which is
basically what we
worked on uh we we used a couple of
reporter lines here which
the dyer lab received as gifts from
their collaborators
and using these reporter lines we
basically optimized
a protocol um that was that where
whereby we could uh differentiate
ipscs from 15 different individuals
efficiently into retinal organoids with
a good yield
and a decent morphology
we also saw that our retinal organoids
they are
are functional so um
we have we have we have
we've seen retinal pigment epithelial
cells juxtaposed
with photoreceptors which basically
suggest the formation of a functional
photoreceptor signaling
and we've also seen that older retinal
organoids when we played them on a
multi-electrode array and provide them
light stimulus
we were able to record a wavelength
specific life response from the retinal
ganglion cells
in these organoids which basically
suggest a functional
a pathway between photoreceptors and
retinal ganglion so we have functional
retinal organoids
that we could derive from multiple
individuals so once we had the protocol
um we worked very closely with jackie
who's an excellent postdoc in the dyer
lab
so um what jackie basically did was um
jackie and her other collaborators they
basically collected
um uh donor cells from
15 different retinoblastoma patients uh
carrying
a different a wide-ranging
mutants uh sorry mutations in the in the
rb1
locus uh they then um generated ips
lines from these
15 different individuals we then
screened the ips clones and we selected
the clones
we did a neural reset formation essay
and we selected the clones that had high
neurogenic potential
and we were then able to differentiate
ips lines from each of the 15 patients
into retinal organoids
jackie then took these organoids and she
dissociated on at 45 days of
differentiation dissociated them into
single cells and injected them
into a materially into immunocompromised
mice
and after about a year she was able to
see that
seven out of the 15 organoids 15
patients specific organoids were able to
generate a retinoblastoma
which is a tumor of the eye in these
mice
and we could uh they could they could
basically confirm this by histology
um and they also looked at the dna
methylation profile in these
um in these organoid derived
retinoblastomas and they found that
uh the organoid tumors they clustered
with the patient's tumors and the
xenografts
uh they also did single cell rna-seq on
these uh on these retinoblastomas and
found that the organoid derived tumors
again they look remarkably similar to
the
patient derived tumors as well as the
patient derived xenograft
with regard to cell type identity and
proliferation
and this work is we're about to publish
this work
it's in the final stages of submission
um in the second example we worked in
collaboration with
dr fabio de montes the de montes lab
studies aging and
degeneration in drosophila as their
modal system but what they wanted to
know was
they wanted to see if stress induced
neuro degeneration is something that can
be modeled
in a in a human organoid system
so uh the demontis lab basically working
with drosophila they identified a unique
pathway they found that
if you apply proteosomal stress to
skeletal muscle in drosophila
the muscle releases a myokine called
amira
which is able to induce a
neuroprotective effect in brit in in the
retina and brain of the drosophila
so for example they found that
drosophila that expressed a pathogenic
form of the huntington protein they have
these
protein aggregates in the eye however if
you over express amiral
in the skeletal muscle of these
drosophila these aggregates disappear
similarly drosophila that express a
mutant form of the tau protein they
have um they have degenerated
photoreceptors because of this a protein
aggregation
however if you over express amiral in
the skeletal muscles then this
degeneration again
can be rectified so uh they looked into
this pathway a little bit more and they
they found that uh the this effect of uh
this neuroprotective effect of amira
is mediated by our maltose and so the
demonitis lab wanted to know if
this uh pathway um which is active in
drosophila is is it conserved
in humans is is this is this something
that that can be
seen in in a human in the human brain uh
as in in a human system as well so for
that we um
we generated the cortical organoids and
we decided to test
this pathway in um in cortical organoids
by looking at uh heat induced
neurodegeneration now the lab did a
bunch of essays but there's one essay
that i'm going to
highlight here which we did in my lab so
we basically took
uh mature cortical organoids these are
two organoids one treated
control one is a control and the other
was treated with maltose
which which they show which the lab
showed in drosophila has this
neuroprotective effect
um and then we used heat shock as
a means to induce neurodegeneration now
before heat shock
both of these organoids have a strong
spontaneous network activity
uh after seven hours of heat shock uh
maltose treated organoids continued to
have a
strong activity but activity completely
disappeared in the control organized
because of the degeneration induced by
the heat shock and even after 18 hours
of following 18 hours of recovery
following the heat shock following the
end of the heat shock
uh the maltose treated organoids still
have strong spontaneous network activity
whereas the control organoids
barely recovered any activity at all
uh so this uh we recently published this
work in cell metabolism so this
basically and this is a good example of
how
um uh human brain organoids can be used
to validate
findings uh from uh from a different
model system in this case
drosophila which i think is uh pretty
cool
so to summarize this part of my talk i
basically showed you
that ipscs can be differentiated into
these self-organizing 3d structures that
mimic parts of the brain
called organoids and these can be
depending on the protocol that you
design and develop these can be region
specific
however variability amongst organized is
a problem and using a reporter line and
screening organoids
um for specific endpoints or for
specific epidemic features
is very useful to address this
variability
um to characterize brain organized the
different assays can be done but the the
three sort of fundamental aspects of
characterization
involve immunostaining to look at the
cyto architecture within the organoid
transcriptome analysis to look at the
proportion of different cell types
that are present within the organoid and
how pure the organized organoid is
whether it's contaminated by lineages
from neighboring regions of the brain
and by doing a functional assay which
essentially is to um
uh show its physiological relevance
um i showed you that we we in in our
department we've used human ipc's to
model to generate patient-specific
retinoblastoma patient-specific retinal
organoids which were able to generate a
patient's specific latino blastoma and
immunocompromised mice
and these organoid derived
retinoblastomas have um
the same molecular profile as patient
tumors
i also showed you that we've also in our
department have been able to use
ipscs to model stress-induced
neurodegeneration
by looking at the neuronal activity
spontaneous and neuronal network
activity in mature cortical organoids in
response
to a thermal stress and in response to
treatment with and without
neuroprotective factors
that were discovered in the lab um so
basically by
in this project we were able to
translate findings from drosophila to
humans
which i think is pretty exciting
uh and finally i want to thank kyle and
priyanka
who are members of my lab um
who are very hardworking excellent
brilliant people that are very i was
very fortunate to
hire i want to thank all the members
of of my department that we work very
closely with that we collaborate with
um members of the dyer lab zacharenko
northcot and demontes lab
the dnb operation support team
the cytogenetics core at saint jude does
all our karyotyping and the center for
advanced genomic engineering which is
run by dr chandra miller
they have basically created they created
a lot of reported lines as well as
isogenic
disease specific lines for us for uh
uh multiple projects that we did and
finally sanju is an amazing place to
work
at and if anyone's interested looking
for a job i would highly highly
recommend
coming to century it's just an amazing
place to work at thank you everyone for
listening and i will be very happy to
take questions
thank you dr nityananda for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started we've already got
some great questions that came in from
the audience
so we're going to start with this one
first
how much optimization time do you
typically plan
for when bringing in a new line
so um so it basically
well it kind of depends on what we want
to do downstream with the line
if it is um
if it is a long term differentiation if
it is a quick
essay then you know maybe
just a couple of months if it is a long
term differentiation then we kind of
plan to do
several experiments in parallel um
it depends on the protocol that we are
using so it's kind of hard to predict if
we have if we're using a protocol that
is that we've done
many times that has been fully optimized
then
it's easier to um you know tweak it
uh play around with certain conditions
just to make it work better for the line
but if you have protocol that you're
still you know trying to figure out
we're still working through then that
obviously takes longer so it's kind of
hard to um
determine but um so anytime we
we start working with a new line the
first thing we do is stereotype them
that's very very important because if
your line has a bad karyotype or even if
you have like two percent of the
population with a with a chromosomal
abnormality that's going to quickly take
over the entire culture and that's going
to ruin all your downstream experiments
so karyotyping is the first thing that
we do
and then we do we'll do like a neural
rosette formation essay to make sure
that it is able
to generate uh neural cells at a you
know a decent efficiency
and then everything after that is um um
it just depends on the protocol and the
aim of the experiment
great thank you so much moving on to our
next question which
is a two-part question for you so what
is the best way to keep organoids
healthy in long-term culture
and the second part is are bioreactors
the only option
yeah that's a good question so um the
for long-term culture we've tried
different
um ways to maintain organoids long-term
um and it's especially important if
you're if you want to get to a stage
where the neurons are mature and they
are firing and if you want to like study
all of that then you need to keep the
organized healthy and
and maturing and differentiating for a
long time
so the the things that the thing that
works best for us one is as i mentioned
in my presentation agitation so
bioreactors are expensive
uh if you do not want to purchase a
bioreactor
i'm hoping that bioreactors become more
and more common in labs and the price
goes down and there are like multiple
right and we don't we don't really have
that many commercially available
systems that that are affordable and can
be used um established easily in the lab
uh the alternative would be to use
orbital shakers which we also uh which
we also use
uh so you can essentially put your
organoid in a 24 well plate low
attachment plate or a 48 well low
attachment plate and we put them place
them on an orbital shaker
and then we uh we move them at like 80
rpm or 90 rpm
and the entire orbital shaker is
basically inside the incubator and there
are several that you can purchase which
are small compact and they don't really
buy
they don't cause any vibration you can
just put them inside the incubator and
move your organoids around that also
helps a lot
um with the growth of the organoids
uh the longer the organoids grow in
culture the more necrosis they will
start to
get in the center so all organoids will
have a necrotic core they'll have a
necrotic center because the nutrients
and gas they just cannot reach the
center of the organoid
that is unavoidable so one thing you can
do to
reduce the size of necrosis is cut the
organoids into smaller pieces
periodically so
after a certain age let's say after like
day 35 or 14
every uh one or two weeks we'll take the
organoids and we'll cut them into
smaller pieces usually into in
in half or in like three pieces and then
put them back in the bioreactor and
continue
cutting the organoids into pieces every
now and then that really helps with
controlling the size of the necrosis in
the center of the organoid and keeping
the organoid growing
uh long term and the last thing i would
say is uh
changing a media uh frequently i mean i
know media is expensive and we don't
want to waste media
but we've noticed that if you change the
entire changing half the media if you
change the entire media in the culture
and do it every let's say four or five
days uh that's very very helpful in
keeping the
culture healthy
thank you so much and it looks like we
have time for one more question
so this audience member was wondering if
you could speak a little bit more to the
variability in psc line in terms of
working with them
for example like handling with them
so uh the the ipsc lines themselves
um when you start working with different
ipsc lines you notice that
uh they can have the the the mo the
the undifferentiated uh pr ips line
itself can have like different
morphologies
so there is no um
just by looking at an ips line it's kind
of sometimes it can be hard to uh
tell whether it's uh uh it's going to be
a good line or not on
or if it's going to uh if it's going to
differ from the other ips lines when you
differentiate when you start
differentiating it into neurons
because the morphology of the ips lines
kind of varies a bit sometimes
we haven't really found any correlation
between what the ips line looks like
under the microscope versus with with
what type of neurons it's able to
differentiate into
um the uh
the only thing i can suggest is that um
like as i said
i mean making sure the ips lines don't
become over confluent that is very very
important
and if we do have ips lines that are uh
a variable
in terms of like um just the morphology
or the appearance of the lines
uh oftentimes if it's a pressure sample
then we'll do a fax purification so
we'll basically just stain the lines
with
two cell surface pluripotency markers
and we'll do like a facts purification
and uh uh purify just the cells that are
uh
that have high expression of the
prepregnancy markers and grow those and
and discard everything else um that is
only for like very pressure samples
because that's not a fool proof method
uh uh
a lot of those uh cells purified by
facts will also
after a couple of passages they might
start differentiating as well so
um but yeah so um in terms of handling
ips lines there's nothing much
there's not much that you can do to like
avoid variability except
karyotyping them frequently making sure
they're not overgrown
uh just handling them properly and um
the the variability the majority of the
variability comes from
the reprogramming process the aberrant
epigenetic reset the reprogramming
process itself so
uh instead of in fact my personal
recommendation would be instead of
spending time
trying to like you know uh uh make a
culture better
i would say just derive multiple clones
from the donor because the
it's very easy to drive multiple clones
from the donor it's not really that much
more work than deriving three clones
uh and then just screen the clones and
before before expanding and banking them
just screen the clones and identify the
ones that
seem best for your purpose and then
expand and bank those
thank you so much dr nithyananda for
your time today
and your important research we would
also like to thank
labyrinth and our sponsor stem cell
technologies for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
all of their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information that you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
labyrints will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
thank you for joining us until next time
bye bye everyone